john doernboss is a two-time nfl pro
bowler and played 11 seasons with the
philadelphia eagles john was not only
one of the best long snappers of all
time he's also an amazing magician and
he's hosting america's got talent las
vegas live welcome to the show buddy
yeah baby this is rockstar happy to be
here man so good to see you man it's so
good to see when did you discover your
love of magic so i was 12 uh and and we
all go through stuff right so i lost my
parents when i was 12 and went into a
foster home for about eight months and i
actually started shuffling cards and i
got into magic it's the only time the
world quieted only time i was a kid wow
so and then it just turned into this and
so uh here we are today and so when you
were playing for the eagles and a couple
other teams would you practice like your
magic tricks on donovan mcnab and other
players like that oh it's the best and
we'd also do poker games right so
if i deal things can go my way you have
a car in your pocket yeah yeah and you
know for me it was a great way to
differentiate myself all these guys
would have events and so i got to meet
people get invited as the athlete and
the entertainment so dude i lived at
rock star life for 14 years man well you
still live in a rock star life because
were you down on america's got talent as
well you tried out on the show yeah yeah
so i was on season 11. i was a finalist
uh lost to the 12 year old with the
ukulele people watched the show you know
then i got called back to do the
champions i was a finalist in that as
well and so that led me to you know
other other opportunities and here we
are in vegas that's great so let's talk
about the show happening here in las
vegas welcome do you perform your show
you just host it yeah so i perform at
hosting every bit i do i do about 20
minutes throughout yeah taking the stage
with deadly games you mean throwing
knives at people if you have not seen
cody lee and if you're not familiar with
cody lee's story
he is an autistic kid who is a music
savant it is a show stopper i've been
able to see the top acts in the world
hang out with him to watch this kid live
has seriously been one of the coolest
things i've ever done in my life and
he's there at the luxor part of the show
he is what's harder doing man be honest
yep doing magic there's no question
we're playing against the dallas cowboys
no question well if i mess up a card
trick what i might get a paper cut you
know what i mean you messed up an nfl
game and you got you know you affect the
spread and people are gambling all of a
sudden you're doing that
when you're playing the game
you get death threats if you if you mess
up in a game well i'm not going to say
it but it has happened really for you my
gosh it's everyone's everywhere like
it's intense right uh you know what do i
get nervous so i this is no joke i don't
ask me why but i used to pretend i was
matt damon and the whole thing was a
script it was a movie so just one take
get out of here union guys want to go
home it's cold so in my head i would
take away the pressure yeah and just act
like we were filming a movie go out
there and do your bit and then get back
to the bench have my little hot
chocolate and that was the way i kind of
would trick my own mind wow that's true
story i can kind of see the matt damon
look here come on baby the board
identity are you kidding me hey two-time
pro bowl what's that like playing in the
pro bowl unbelievable so here's what's
really cool i was so excited to go and
then it was like john you made the pro
bowl awesome it's the one year we're not
going to hawaii we're going to do it in
arizona come on so then okay so then
time passes hey john you made the pro
bowl yes we're going to white actually
no it's the second time we're not going
to go away we're going to miami so i
went to the pro bowl the two times it
wasn't i don't know why well you're here
in town john it's great to have you on
the show man thank you thanks for being
here america's got talent las vegas live
at the luxor hotel and casino for more
information and to purchase tickets
visit luxor.com